Kolkata, located in the West Bengal state
of India, is a loud, chaotic, and thought
provoking city.
Ancient decaying buildings share the streets
with a superabundance of honking yellow taxis,
a multitude of pedestrians, and roadside vendors
selling everything conceivable.
Coming up are eleven of the most memorable
things I did when I visited Kolkata, India.
Number one is the home of mother teresa.
I am here at the entrance of mother teresa's
home, which is just known as mother's home.
Mother Teresa said, intense love is not measured,
it just gives, so she really lived that example,
and we are going to go into her house, there's
a museum, her tomb is there as well as her
room where she stayed when she lived here.
I'm trying to keep my voice low because it's
a really quiet and special place.
But Mother Teresa did a lot of her work here,
and you can actually go in and see the tomb
of Mother Teresa.
Really an amazing place to visit.
Number two is Kolkata's famous Victoria Memorial,
one of the most important landmarks of the
city.
I'm here at the Victoria Memorial Hall in
Kolkata, India.
It's a cool morning, and I just paid four
rupees entrance which is to the garden, and
then if you pay one hundred fifty rupees you
can go into
the museum.
Number three is the spooky South Park Street
Cemetery.
And I think this place was set up in the seventeen
hundreds sometime, but these are just giant
tombs, and then the whole place is just eerie
from the vegetarian, and the trees and the
flowers, yah, really like ancient looking
tombstones,
Number three is the spooky South Park Street
Cemetery.
Khalighat temple, and this is the oldest Hindu
temple, sixteen hundred years old, this is
the oldest Hindu temple in Kolkata.
Be careful for scammers in this area that
try to guide you around the temple and then
ask for an absurdly unrealistic donation,
don't be afraid to just walk away.
Coming in at number five is the crazy shopping
district around the New Market.
I'm standing outside of Sir Stuart Hogg Market
which is also just known as New Market.
It's a chaotic, and busy area of town, lots
of street food and lots of street shopping,
and just lots of people, it's a crazy chaotic
area, pretty interesting, a lot of things
to do around here.
So the New Market area in Kolkata, India.
Number six is the Indian Museum, which is
also known as the Magic House.
I'm standing just outside of the Indian Museum,
in Kolkata, and this is an extremely popular
museum here and I heard that one of the attractions
here is a four thousand year old Egyptian
mummy.
Ok, I'm standing just outside of the Belur
Math Temple, which is just down there a little
ways, but I've already been there and unfortuantely
they do not allow any photography inside or
even outside of the temple, so this is the
best view I can give you, but it's a really
beautiful sight, this is a nice clean, private,
gated facility, beautiful temple and they
also have a place where you can put your shoes,
a secure place, a free secure place to put
your shoes so that you can enter the temple
to walk around for a little bit.
But a really peaceful place right on the river,
you can also walk along the river.
Belur Math temple.
I'm taking the ferry Belur Math to Dakshineswar
temple, a little ferry ride across the river,
and a little bit down the river.
Number eight is the huge temple complex of
Dakshineswar, located north of Kolkata.
Lots of activity happening, and this is right
along the banks of the river, so you can see
the temple as well as you can go to the river
and you can take a boat there as well as watch,
watch along the river as well.
Below the Howrah bridge and adjacent to the
Mullik Ghat is the colorful bustling flower
market, at number nine.
Right below me is the central flower market
for Kolkata, so if you look down there, it's
bustling with flowers and a big market,
Occupying sun yat sen road, is the early morning
Chinese food terreti market at number ten.
I'm at the morning Terreti bazar market, which
is kind of like a Chinese market.
I'm here to just walk around and also to get
some Chinese food, some breakfast dishes,
Finally at number eleven is the array of marvelous
Kolkata street food.
From the beloved kati rolls to quick snacks
like pani puri, Kolkata will have you licking
your lips.
Kolkata, with more than its share of poverty
and hardships, offers a contrasting view into
the reality of this Indian mega city.
It's not the easiest nor the most convenient
place to visit, but with patience and flexibility,
it provides fascinating rewards, never ending
energy, and countless experiences to digest.
Hey it's Mark here, thank you very much for
watching my video, and please remember to
give it a quick thumbs up.
Also, don't forget to click the subscribe
button so you don't miss my upcoming food
videos.